Hey Youtubers it's Charlie! Thank you everyone that's submitting questions for this week's
Arrow / Flash Q&A
Just like normal, I'm going to start with Flash
stuff and then I'll get into Arrow questions.
I know there's a bunch of big questions about
time travel, what's going on with the
Groundhog's Day situation
and what's up with like the two really
big WTF reveals on Arrow.
So just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet. I'll start with
the easy stuff on The Flash
- the easy time travel explainers.
So yes, episode 16 is going to be Barry
reliving
most the events from episode 15 that
includes:
the conclusion of awkward date,
(remember because
he bailed from the date like early on!)
finding Weather Wizard faster and as a
result of those things he'll probably bump into
Cisco earlier and cause Cisco to do
something differently
which will result in Harrison Wells not
going back and killing him.
Cisco's alive in a lot the future
trailer footage so clearly
something changes to save his life.
Remember the only people that found out
about Harrison Wells
in the original time line where Caitlin
and Cisco
and Cisco's really the only one that
completely figured it out! Caitlin just knows
that something's weird.
That means it's going to be that much
longer before people figure out who
Harrison Wells really is.
That he's Eobard Thawne. That's why you see
the trailer footage with him talking to
Gideon going,
"Show me the future!" or the footage of him
from episode 18 which is way down the line
the atom crossover with him sitting in
front of ? suit. And there's been the
recent pictures that Rick Cosnett has
taken with Tom Cavanagh.
I'm really interested to see if
Eobard Thawne tries to steer
Eddie Thawne in a certain direction to
ensure his lineage.
For the most part they are sticking with
comic book continuity.
So Iris probably gets married to Barry
like she does in the comics.
Eddie Thawne goes on to
hate Barry for some reason,
and many many years down the road, Eobard Thawne is born,
becomes the Reverse Flash and starts the
war against Barry Allen.
That's where it gets really 'timey whimey'
because it's like you know it's a war
in the future that spills into the past,
that feeds the future even more! It's like
this giant feedback loop of time travel!
Think back to Arrow season 2. By
the time we get the last couple episodes
Slate had already taken over the city. And
it was all about Team Arrow
taking him down. I think that means that
Barry's going to learn who Harrison Wells is
before episode 21, at least episode 22 at
the latest.
So, other questions all kinds of time
travel stuff! PersianMonkeyStudios asks,
"How did Harrison Wells get bloody when
he was getting punched by a recording?"
So technically it was like
him punching himself
and what they were watching was a Speed
Mirage like as he called it.
So he really was punching himself it wasn't
like a physical hologram
punching him. They're a little fuzzy on
exactly how fast he's moving.
I think they'll start to quantify that
as Harrison Wells starts to explain
time travel to Barry in in a deeper way.
Next question. Ryan asks, "Do you think
that in a future season like season 4 or 5
Barry will die and then Wally will take
over as The Flash
and then Bart Owl will be Kid Flash and
Arsenal will get cloned.
So you're thinking, you know, like stuff that they've
done from the comics and the cartoons before.
No. I think that Grant Gustin will always
be the main Flash. They'll have
other Flashes come on. They'll totally do
more of the Flash family.
Even like Jesse Quake! That'll be cool too.
I think what will happen is
is they may come on briefly but the show
always reset
by the finale. I think we'll get the
Black Racer and all kinda crazy stuff!
Barry Allen could get trapped in the Speed Force
for a couple episodes at some point but
he'll always come back.
Like they'll do their version of Arrow
killing Oliver Queen.
He was away for a while. He wasn't in a
couple episodes in a big way.
So I think they'll do something like
that, but Grant Gustin will always be
there lead actor.
They've kinda that in the comics where
you've had like multiple Flash Family
like where you had Jay Garrick and Wally
West during the Wally West run.
So they'll do stuff like that where you have more than one Flash on a show,
but Barry Allen will always be
the main Flash
Next question though. Dynasty Heroes
asks, "So is Eddie Thawne villain then?"
Well not not quite yet. I think he's
getting there. I think by the end of the season
that's what the tease is. If they do turn
him into a villain and if they do go
straight from the comic books and he's
like a Hunter Voloman type character
with the Thawne name, you know as part
of the Thawne lineage, then I think
that he would be the big bad in season
two. It's kind of like Arrow going from season
one to season two.
Season 1, Malcolm Merlyn - Oliver's
biggest villain.
He's like the biggest Green Arrow villain in
the comics too. Or one of the biggest villains.
The season 2 villain - Slade started out
as Oliver's friend.
So, just like that on The Flash, Eddie Thawne
starts out as Barry's friend in season one,
becomes the villain in season two. I
think that's like a logical place to go.
But there will be other villains, other
really big villains. That includes Rogues,
Justice League villains, anybody else that
they feel would be good match
for the other characters in the show.
Beyond the second Reverse Flash, I think
it's a little too soon to speculate on
big season two villains.
Gorilla Grodd I think is definitely on
the list. He's always gonna come back.
He's way amazing to ride the bench.
Next question. WWEFan asks,
"Will Barry ever interact with his future
self and will Barry ever find Harrison Wells
is Eddie Thawne? I assume you meant Eobard Thawne.
Second question.
I think I already answered yeah.
He'll totally figure that out you know, before the last one or two episodes
as for your other question - yeah.
Definitely he will talk to himself.
In that clip from the trailer, he's
punching himself. So at some point he's
going to try and stop himself from doing
something
and his other self will say, "Fuck you
buddy!"
I think episode 16 will explain a lot of that.
Next question. Alan Law asks, "The new
Suicide Squad:
Amanda Waller, Deathstroke, Boomerang
Weather Wizard and Nyssa."
That would be awesome! I don't see
Nyssa - I feel like she's going to
take Ra's al Ghul's place. They'll find a way
for Oliver to back out of the deal
and Nyssa to take his place - become the
heir again. Really Cupid is like the
replacement person in a Suicide Squad.
I think depending on fan reaction to the
Suicide Squad episode next week
they'll mix and match characters. Every
time they bring the
Suicide Squad back on the show
it changes just a little bit because
they don't use it that often.
But I do think at some point, they'll bring
Captain Boomerang
back on as a Suicide Squad member.
If not in season 4 then in season 5. A lot
of that depends on the actors' availability.
Next question. Bartu asks, "I hope they do
Flashpoint but how will they
put Batman, Cyborg, Aquaman in the TV show?"
Okay so think about it this way.
"What is Flashpoint?"
All it really is is
the Reverse Flash
trying to turn Barry Allen into a living
paradox. You really don't need
any other characters for that. Really the
Reverse Flash just allows Barry Allen to
save his mother.
And that completely changes the
timeline via Butterfly Effect.
The war between Atlantis and the surface
world and all the other stuff that's going on,
those are just side effects.
They're not necessary.
The Reverse Flash doesn't care about them.
He just cares about killing Barry Allen.
And the only way he can do that
is by turning him into a living paradox. So
when I talk about Flashpoint paradox
with reference to the show, that I'm
talking about. Just the Reverse Flash
eliminating Barry Allen without
eliminating himself from the timeline.
Next question.
Oo2k10 asks, "So it looks like you're
asking about 2 Barry Allens
in the past, maybe merging and becoming
one Barry Allen. No.
Because there's 2 of them fighting in the
trailer, there's very clearly
going to be 2 of them,
one of them will leave and leave the
original one there. I know it gets into the
multiverse territory
don't overthink it too much before the
show explains it. What I think they'll do
is Harrison Wells will explain to Barry
how he can return to the original timeline
without messing stuff up.
Because very clearly Eobard Thawne has
a lot of experience in time traveling in
trying to change the past
without completely messing up his own
future. Next question.
David asks, "So is Iris was gonna know
who The Flash is
or will she not know since Barry went
back in time?" Well she'll only know
if Barry repeats all those events in the
same way. He could I think what will
happen is as he'll do something different
and she won't find out.
Andrew Kreisberg was pretty upfront with
them having fun with episode 16 in
Barrie doing things differently,
so I think it'll lead to a different
outcome kinda resetting
a lot of the WTF crap stuff.
Cisco won't die. Iris won't find out.
Barry will defeat Weather Wizard and save Joe.
That would just allow things to progress
status quo for the next couple episodes
as things slowly spin out of control
more and more.
Next question. Yeow asks, "Any chance
the TV Flash
crossing over with the movie Flash?" That
they would be like the smallest
cameos if it happens and I don't think
it's gonna happen.
Ezra Miller is playing the movie version
to the Flash. It sounds like he's going to
be the Barry Allen Flash too. And Warner Brothers is gonna be like,
"TVs and movies - completely different universes.
Deal with it!"
I've heard rumors that the
Batman-be-Superman trailer has
footage Ezra Miller in as Barry Allen but
there's no confirmation on that. I have
no idea what the
movie version of The Flash is gonna look like
I wouldn't worry about it too much. By
the time we actually get to
that Flash / Green Lantern movie,
there will be so many seasons at the TV
Flash that I think people will identify
more with the Grant Gustin Flash than
they will with the Ezra Miller Flash
So moving into general Arrow questions.
Harry asks,
"If Shadow's alive, why did Oliver let
Deathstroke kill his mother,
kidnap a sister, and go all crazy in the
city?"
I think the simplest answer is that that
was not shadow that was either
a sister or a clone. It would be pretty WTF
if it was a clone.
And surprise surprise you know why would
she appear in the
one place the Oliver happens to be?
That's an awful big coincidence.
And why hasn't Oliver mentioned her in
the future? Either because
she died in the past in a flashback she'll die eventually,
Or it really her sister and Oliver was
trying to protect her by not telling
Slade about her.
just to be clear though, that was the
exact same actors that played Shadow in
seasons 1 and 2.
Next question though. Mark asks, "Since
magic is in the Arrowverse,
I hope they get a Constantine crossover.
So I picked this one for very specific reason.
i've heard rumors that Constantine has
been canceled, which is sad,
but that does free up the character
and Matt Ryan to crossover.
If they gotten picked up because NBC is a
different network, you just made it
nearly impossible for him to cross over
but if it's cancelled in NBC frees up
the character,
then it's a lot easier to happen, because
I think Matt Brian would totally be down
to do stuff like that.
That also kinda getting into actor
availability too, but that there's some
issues with rights
and different networks, so it's a little
more complicated,
it's not simple answer. Next question.
Dark Vengeance asks,
"Imagine Ra's resurrected Sara. I know
it's impossible but that be big WTF
moment for the season finale."
Well it's not impossible, but I think you
know, general assumption
is that Katie Lutz will be playing a different
character on the spinoff show.
I don't feel like they would have
introduced the Lazurus Pit if they were
going to resurrect somebody.
But that doesn't mean that they couldn't
also resurrect multiple people.
I would be very very surprised if they
made any official announcements about
who Katie Lutz is playing,
before the Arrow finale this year. They
might
even way to Comic-Con to announce it, but
they'll be filming the pilot for the
spinoff show soon so they'll have to
have some outdoor scenes
so we will get a look if she's gonna be
wearing a costume we will see what it is!
It's like somebody will snipe the set! So
spoilers are not spoilers...
people will find out before the summer. I
think what everyone's hoping is is
she'll come back as Sara,
like it'll be Sara being
resurrected. It'll be some twisted
version of her.
And that'll explain why she's not going
to be living in Starling city.
Thank you so much to everyone for so
many questions, they are always a ton of fun to do.
I know there's still a whole bunch of
questions about Second Reverse Flash,
what's happening with Eddie Thawne...
I think most of those questions are going to
be answered in the next three episodes.
The only thing I'm really worried about
is if they
lose Tom Cavanagh for season 2 The
Flash. He is so amazing
that it's like you know, 'Can the show
maintain its momentum
if they lose one of their best
characters?' That's actually a good question for you
guys: Do you feel like I mean, air of season
2,
they had Slade Wilson amazing character;
Manu Bennett amazing actor.
Do you feel like Rick Cosnett could rise
to the level of Manu Bennett as a
season 2 villain?
It feels like his character has been
riding the bench for most of the season,
so it's really hard to get a read on him
as an actor. I think that'll change in
the next couple episodes.
So don't forget new episodes Arrow and
The Flash next week - be sure to subscribe
to get my videos. It's gonna be
a little bit Terminator / little bit
Groundhog's Day - scary / funny at the same time.
Gonna be a lot of fun! So, if you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for my Flash video, probably one of the
best episodes this season.
And you click here for this week's agent to
SHIELD if you haven't seen it yet.
Thank you so much for watching! I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Now let's all do the thing!